[Musik]
jedes stück ausziehen was gedacht und
jetzt willkommen beim ein video jahr
wollte ich hoffe natürlich gibt es gut
eigentlich kann ich euch vor wir heute
mal mit dem video anfang
nach kurzer zeit und zwar bis heute
geschafft unser wohnzimmer noch ein
bisschen auszubauen bis hin zu
verschönern dazu mache ich einfach mal
kurz das licht aus das schild kennen ja
die meisten von euch wahrscheinlich noch
aber wir haben jetzt hier noch ein neues
schild sieht auch echt cool aus hier
noch so einen coolen teppich darunter
das so eigentlich wollten in der ukraine
falls ihr eine möbelfirma seit und so
und vielleicht noch ein bisschen was
ausstatten wollte er gerne also ich bin
dafür eine kooperation auf aber an sich
bin ich schon zufrieden jetzt unter uns
sagen unser herz tagen noch halben jahr
auch endlich mal also das ist echt cool
jetzt ist aber natürlich klar die
meisten von euch haben sie
wahrscheinlich am titel auch schon
gelesen ungefähr verantworten kann das
video von mir die unnötigsten produkte
von supreme weiß es noch nicht gesehen
habt schaut hier auf jeden fall wo ich
gesagt hab ja leute wenn dieses video
15.000 likes bekommt es gab halt so ein
feuerlöscher von supreme auf ebay für
200 euro oder so und ich habe gesagt
hier bei 15 tracks bestelle ich dieses
ding und ihr habt es jetzt nicht 15.000
like sondern wirklich schon 27001 oder
28.000 likes auf diesem video ich hoffe
blieb er dann logischerweise nichts
anderes übrig als diesen scheiß
feuerlöscher zu bestellen
beziehungsweise ich wollte ihn bestellen
das problem war nur das kam mir alles
irgendwie ein bisschen unseriös vor
natürlich ist man da eigentlich
abgesichert über diesen käuferschutz
aber ich habe mir gedacht bevor das
jetzt ewig dauert bis dieser vorher
schon da ist machen wir einfach heute
und seinen eigenen supreme feuerlöscher
ich habe mir einen eigenen feurig
so bestellt der ist gestern angekommen
und ich war noch in so einem graffiti
laden und haben sprayfarbe gekauft wir
haben jetzt schon abend alle sind denkt
ihm schlafen
außer mir wir starten jetzt heute
draußen den supreme feuerlöscher und
eigentlich können wir noch testen oder
wissen also leute ich will mal kurz zum
feuerlöscher und denen muss man erst mal
aufmachen und hören wir da ist auch
nicht der feuerlöscher drin so leute
dieses paket hier interessen angekommen
ist echt schwer so ein feuerlöscher der
weg etwas und ich hoffe das ist jetzt
auch der denn ich wollte natürlich und
war schon aus noch nie so gefalle
geschlagen ausgelassen haben ja heute so
bayerischer ist auf jeden fall
es dürfte na ja gut aber auf dieser
seite nicht aber auf dieser so etliche
nation so würdest du nicht sagen wie das
training komplett
er muss richtig geil aus den selbst das
hier musste in diesem supreme farbton
ich habe extra den richtigen original
supreme fraktion gewählt und dann halt
einfach noch hier die weiße farbe und
ich habe eben auch hier dieses supreme
vor lang gebastelt
das war echt eine menge arbeit die
werden wir gleich später dann aufkleben
und das halt aus rain bin ich auch mal
gespannt wie das dann aussieht also ich
hoffe das wird geil
also leute ich würde sagen wir man gar
nicht lange sondern fanden sofort man
hier kommt jetzt zu prim drauf ich bin
gespannt ob das klappt dann bei ebay
auktionen kommen
das macht auch als video probiert und
wenn der jedoch sieht ständig den selber
bei ebay leihen und dann könnt ihr den
haben
ich hatte mir den fluss
ja das ist gut ich würde eigentlich
immer mehr stellen als deko okay leute
wir machen das so wenn er cool aussieht
dann kommt ja erst mal bei mir
hintergrund als deko und irgendwann
stellte ich ihm dann bei ebay ein und
dann könnt ihr den ersteigern und das
geld davon wird dann spendet dort so
schauen wir mal aber es muss ja auch
erstmal klappen also wir gehen jetzt los
bis gleich
weißt du was du heute gedacht hab ich
das auto machen könnte mit sokrates
projekten supreme losgelaufen
herr machen doch dein mustern also was
man hat ja das gibt's hier
also warten wir auf dieses video sagen
also wieder sagen wir diesmal 20.000 20
20 1030 meinauto.de hier sogar drauf ja
auch an die seiten so ja einst so
wichtig hier drüber ich bin echt
gespannt ob das auch das darauf gut hält
er legt den doch hin
[Musik]
das ist schon krass ist soweit ich mag
es einmal kurz den komplett rot das
dauert ein bisschen
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt so richtig was die
gangster aus film und musik wie das
weißt du
[Musik]
so leute jetzt geht's los hier mit dem
cluster aber schön ausgespielten egal
wenn das jetzt leicht von oben drauf
sprießt von weiter weg dann passt es
perfekt da hinten ist doch genauso
ja was diese was du so leute ich ziehe
ist jetzt ab ich bin ich gespannt ich
glaube so krass gut ist dass jetzt nicht
oder doch ich glaube schon übertrieben
geil das ist übertrieben ist gut
eigentlich ich will auch so ein ich weiß
ich weiß von halten sich fast voll
merkel einigt man sich auf so eine
eigene künstlerische schaden weil sie
cool aber ich habe mir das noch ein
bisschen akkurater erhofft sagen so aber
es ist natürlich schwer soll nicht so
der profi sprayer eigentlich habe ich
das voll und die immer
wir haben den süffigen feuerwehr
schätzen in den kofferraum geladen und
fahren jetzt irgendwo hin wo wieder
einmal ausprobieren können ob da
wirklich so nicht so power rauskommt
ich bin gespannt auf jeden fall sieht ja
echt meiner meinung nach cool aus
künstlerisch und das ist ja das was
zählt die künstlerische freiheit ist
habe ich im letzten jahr gelernt auch
ein super begriff sollt ihr euch
vielleicht auch am besten gleich merken
bis gleich
[Musik]
was sie mögen
da ist
mega spaß gemacht wurde
aber es ist so kalt war spitze guckt
euch mal die spitze an dies jetzt
einfach weil ich so leid ich bin jetzt
schon wieder zu hause gerne nächsten tag
und da oben besteht jetzt der
feuerlöscher hat er jetzt seinen platz
gefunden ich bin das ist eigentlich ein
cooler damit du dir nochmal genau im
detail seht hier mal ein kurzer
ausschnitt
juni ist ja heute so sieht das die aus
schreibt eure machen dazu in die
kommentare findet er ist cool geworden
natürlich ist ja jetzt nicht so perfekt
das supreme logo hätte besser drauf
kommen können ich habe es leider nicht
besser hinbekommen ich hoffe natürlich
dass sie dadurch trassen gefallen
also lasst auf jeden fall nach oben da
vor allem für die auto aktion mit dem
bock habt dass ich auf das auto
beziehungsweise auf mein auto so ein
supreme doch manchmal bin ich auch
gespannt ob das klappen könnte ansonsten
schaut euch auf jeden fall das video von
vor eineinhalb wochen an die zähne
unnötig sind produkte von screen ist
auch cool geworden einfach jetzt gleich
verlinkt und jackson ins tor gemacht wir
sehen uns wie immer dann vor was ich
morgen wieder am morgen gibt's neues
cooles video machen ist ja auch endlich
wieder wochenende und war eine coole
nächtliche aktion gestern hat spaß
gemacht also leute rein